>> Tucker: CONGRESS IS DAYS AWAY
FROM ANOTHER GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN.
SENATOR JOHN McCAIN RELEASED HIS
IDEA OF AN IMMIGRATION
COMPROMISE.
HIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE AMNESTY
FOR MILLIONS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS IN RETURN FOR ZERO
CONCESSIONS.
NO WALL.
IT'S AN ABSURD IDEA THAT NOBODY
STAYS SERIOUSLY INCLUDING THE
WHITE HOUSE.
WHERE ARE WE?
WHAT IS THE STATE OF PLAY AND
WHERE ARE WE GOING.
THIS IS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
I THINK IT'S A BAFFLING POSITION
THAT THE LEFT IS IN RIGHT NOW.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS BUILD A
WALL WHICH YOU SAY DOESN'T WORK
ANYWAY.
WHAT IS WRONG WITH THAT?
>> I WOULD HAVE ASK THE SAME
OVER THE PAST MONTH THAT OFFERED
THAT.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT DESERVES
CREDIT FOR PUTTING HIS CARDS ON
THE TABLE.
SENATORS McCAIN AND COONS DID
THAT TODAY.
PRESIDENT BUSH COULD DO.
THE DEAL IS THERE.
HE HAS TO CLOSE IT.
>> Tucker: THE STUMBLING BLOCK
IS THE WALL.
PEOPLE AGAINST THE WALL ARE FOR
INEFFECTIVE.
MEXICO ARGUES THE WALL WON'T
WORK.
WHY ARE THEY MAD ABOUT?
>> I WANT A SECURE BORDER THAT
KEEPS US SAFE.
I WANT THE AMERICAN TAXPAYER FOR
COMBINATION OF TECHNOLOGY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> Tucker: I DON'T BELIEVE YOU.
>> WHY NOT?
>> Tucker: WE ARE TALKING $20
MILLION.
>> YOU DON'T BELIEVE THAT I
CARRY ABOUT THE SECURITY AND THE
AMERICAN TAXPAYER?
>> Tucker: NOT AT WALL.
TALKING ABOUT $20 BILLION ON THE
WALL AND PEOPLE DON'T CARE ABOUT
SPENDING IN ANY OTHER PART OF
GOVERNMENT DON'T WANT IT.
>> WE SHOULD DO THE TUCKER
CARLSON DEAL.
PROTECT DREAMERS AND BUILD THE
WALL.
>> Tucker: TRUMP JUST OFFERED TO
GIVE MILLIONS OF SO-CALLED
DREAMERS CITIZENSHIP.
NOT JUST LEGAL STATUS.
THEY CAN VOTE IN EXCHANGE FOR
THE WALL.
THE LEFT HATES THE WALL BECAUSE
IT'S A PERMANENT SOLUTION.
YOU COULD TAKE THEM DOWN.
YOU COULD HIRE MORE AGENTS.
>> WE ARE IF FAVOR OF A NARROW
SOLUTION LIKE YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT:
PROTECTING DREAMERS AND THE
BORDER.
>> Tucker: ARE NOT.
YOU ARE FOR BORDERS FOR THAT CAN
REPEALED.
YOU WOULD BE FOR A WALL?
>> IF THE BORDER PATROL ALONG
THAT ARE ON THE EXPERTS ON THE
BORDER SAYING WE NEED A WALL IN
>> I AM IN FAVOR OF EXPERTS MAKE
POLICY.
>> Tucker: BUT THERE IS AMERICA.
THE PUBLIC GETS TO MAKE POLICY
TO MAKE RIGHT DECISIONS.
SOME WILL SAY WE NEED A WALL.
>> Tucker: YOU THINK A BORDER
PATROL AGENT OR AN EXPERT SHOULD
HAVE MORE AUTHORITY THAN VOTERS
IN A DEMOCRACY?
HOW DOES THAT WORK?
>> SOMEONE WHO HAS 30 YEARS OF
PROTECTING OUR NATION KNOWS HOW
TO PROTECT.
>> Tucker: WHY HAVE ELECTIONS AT
ALL?
>> BECAUSE YOU HAVE A POLICY
MAKER.
>> Tucker: WE ELECTED A REALITY
TV STAR WHO WANTED TO BUILD A
WALL AND THEY VOTED FOR THAT AND
HE WON.
IN WASHINGTON, WE ARE SAYING YOU
DON'T GET A WALL.
YOU DON'T KNOW ENOUGH.
THAT'S NOT REALLY A REAL
AMERICAN TAXPAYER.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE COMFORTABLE
WALL.
ANYTHING SHORT OF THAT -- MAYBE
WHY WOULDN'T THEY GET WHAT THEY
WANT IF THIS IS REALLY A
DEMOCRACY?
AND THE VOTERS ARE IMMATERIAL.
>> IF YOU DISRESPECT THEIR